hi schön dass ihr dabei seid bei ZDF
heute live wir gucken heute mal wieder
auf den Krieg in der Ukraine und dort
vor allem auf den Süden der Ukraine wo
Russland aktuell massive befestigungs-
und Verteidigungsanlagen gebaut hat und
baut jetzt kann man sich fragen was
machen die dort warum gibt es überall
mittlerweile recht auffällige aus der
Luft
deutliche Befestigung und
Verteidigungsanlagen und es ist so dass
Russland sich aktuell dort auf etwas
vorbereitet wird auf was alle allgemein
mit Anspannung warten nämlich die
ukrainische Frühjahrsoffensive die
erwartet wird wie diese
Verteidigungsanlagen genauer aussehen
und wo sie sich überall befinden das hat
Jan Schüssler für uns zusammengefasst
die russische Offensive stockt
zeitgleich bereitet sich Russland auf
Kiews gegen Offensive vor eine Analyse
des
us-verteidigungsexperten Brady afric
zeigt eine Übersicht russischer
Verteidigungsanlagen einige der
Befestigungen wurden demnach bereits im
vergangenen Jahr gebaut die neuesten
Anlagen werden aktuell größtenteils in
der Nähe der Frontlinie oder
Stützpunkten gebaut aber auch im
nördlichen Teil der annektierten Krim
sind auf Satellitenaufnahmen einige
Anlagen zu sehen die Systeme bestehen
dabei aus mehreren Befestigungen und
Hindernisse das folgende Beispiel zeigt
eine Anlage zwischen saporichia und
Melitopol zu den russischen
Verteidigungsanlagen gehören tiefe
Gräben und erdwelle vor allem gegen
Panzer auf frisch geflügten Ackerböden
erwarten Experten außerdem Landminen
davor und dahinter kommen vorgefertigte
Verteidigungslinien wie sogenannte
Drachenzähne das sind oftmals höckerförm
ige sperren aus Beton die Panzer stoppen
sollen
ja sogenannte Drachenzähne erdwelle
Gräben all das um die ukrainische
Frühjahrsoffensive zurückzuhalten über
die russische aber auch die ukrainische
Perspektive darauf wollen wir heute
sprechen zu einem mit meinem
zdf-kollegen und Korrespondenten daran
Hasan Sade der uns gleich live aus der
Ukraine zugeschaltet ist und mit dem
Militärexperten Markus zu militärischen
Strategie auf seitens Ukraine und
seitens Russland wenn ihr Fragen an die
beiden habt oder eure Meinung mit uns
teilen wollt dann tut das gerne hier im
Youtube Chat oder per Mail an ZDF heute
- live.at zdf.de jetzt wollen wir aber
unserem Blick noch mal auf diese
Verteidigungsanlagen richten die ihr
gerade gesehen habt und das tun wir
gemeinsam mit Herrn Kreuz der mir
zugeschaltet das Herz bekommt
hallo
Herr Kolb wir haben es gerade von oben
gesehen wir sehen Schützengräben wir
sehen Minenfelder sogenannte
Drachenzähne können Sie uns erläutern
was da gerade auf Seiten Russland
passiert
ja es ist eigentlich das Denken des
Zweiten Weltkriegs dass Sie hier sehen
also man befürchtet eine großflächige
mechanisierte Operation der Ukraine und
man baut entsprechend Hindernisse ins
Gelände also insbesondere auch auf der
Krim sehen Sie diese Befestigung diese
Anlagen die sind in unterschiedlichen
Zustand also wir haben jetzt so die
stärkeren dieser Anlagen gesehen aber
man muss sich zunächst mal zwei Dinge
klar machen es sind keine durchgezogenen
Linien also es ist nicht etwa so etwas
wie die Maginot-Linie aus dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg sondern es sind einfache
vereinzelt in die
geländestellungen integrierte
Anlagen das heißt also es bestehen
Lücken zwischen diesen Anlagen und das
sehen Sie je stärker sie hinein zoomen
in die Karte desto mehr merken sie dass
das naja so nach und nach zusammengebaut
worden ist aber eigentlich nicht nach
einem gesamten strategischen Plan das
andere was man sehen muss ist dass diese
Drachenzähne keine bodenfundamente haben
sie sind ungefähr Knie hoch aber sie
sind direkt auf die Erde aufgesetzt
worden also auch das anders als im
Zweiten Weltkrieg z.B im Westwall wo
diese Strukturen im Boden verankert
waren und mehr als doppelt so hoch
das heißt dass das muss man zunächst mal
immer in Betracht ziehen die Dinge sehen
besser aus als sie in Wirklichkeit sind
aber natürlich sind das Hindernisse im
Gelände und sie sind jetzt schon nicht
so ohne weiteres zu überwinden sondern
man muss dann schon mit einer gewissen
Kraft dadurch kommen aber trotzdem die
Erwartungshaltung die dahinter steckt
ist eben eine eine klassische Land
Operation und ich glaube nicht dass die
ukrainische früher als auch wenn Sie
Ihre in dieser Art ablaufen wird
ja damit Ihr da draußen ist vielleicht
noch ein bisschen besser nachvollziehen
könnt werfen wir jetzt mal einen Blick
auf die Karte auf der eben diese ganzen
verteidigungswelle und Dämme und Gräben
eingezeichnet sind man sieht hier ganz
gut das ist kein durchgängiges rotes
Band sondern das ist wie Herr Kolb hier
gerade gesagt hat relativ lückenhaft je
weiter man rein so sieht man hier sind
auch
vereinzelte Gräben Herr Kolb warum ist
denn hier z.B diese Stadt togmak warum
ist die denn so eingekreist von Gräben
ja das hat zwei Gründe also wenn sie von
togmark aus etwas weiter in
nordwestlicher Richtung schauen auf der
Karte wo der große Stausee des Sniper
sich befindet da läuft im Moment
ungefähr die Frontlinie bei janske das
heißt Trockner liegt nicht allzu weit
von der Front entfernt und vor allem der
zweite Grund topmak ist ein sehr
wichtiger Eisenbahnknoten wir sehen
jetzt leider auf der Karte nicht die
Eisenbahnlinie aber von dort läuft der
russische Nachschub in Richtung
militoppe und in die gesamte Südfront
also bis nach Norbert das heißt wenn Sie
diese Eisenbahnlinie die läuft etwas
südlich der Stadt tokmark wenn Sie die
ausschalten dann unterbinden sie damit
nachhaltig die russische Logistik das
heißt also wenn Sie jetzt das
zusammenzählen die Front steht oben bei
kamianzke die Gräben und
Verteidigungsanlagen das sind Lücken
dazwischen und sie haben einen high
value target wie man so schön sagt
unmittelbar dahinter dann würde sich das
natürlich anbieten als eine Stoßrichtung
für die Ukraine interessanterweise hat
der rechtmäßig gew diese Bürgermeister
von talkmog fährt auch hat gestern
verkündet das offenbar Fahrzeuge in der
Stadt unterwegs sind die die Bewohner
dazu auffordern die Stadt zu verlassen
also zu evakuieren und Russland also die
die russischen
Besatzungsregime und deren
Kollaborateure die haben bereits seit
dem 12 April Zeitungen verbreitet an die
Zivilbevölkerung wo sie auch so ein
Szenario gebracht haben also es ist
denkbar dass das so passieren könnte es
zeigt auf jeden Fall dass die Russen im
Moment ziemlich nervös sind und sich
ebenso fragen wo kommt jetzt dieser
Durchbruch
sie haben gerade von dem sogenannten
mechanisierten Angriff gesprochen mit
dem Russland rechnen können Sie uns noch
mal erläutern was genau das ist
also mechanisierte würde bedeuten dass
die Ukraine dasselbe macht was im
zweiten weltkriegt passiert ist also
sprich eine eine große
Invasion mit vielen Fahrzeugen entlang
einem großen Abschnitt der Frontlinie
also über mehrere hundert Kilometer wir
haben das im Zweiten Weltkrieg sehr
häufig gesehen solche Operationen vor
allem eben in der damaligen Sowjetunion
also riesige Operation mit riesigen
materialverbänden und ähm ich denke das
ist das das Denken was der russischen
Planung so ein bisschen zugrunde liegt
aber ich glaube nicht eben dass das so
passieren
sie haben ja auch gerade schon den
Rückbezug zum Zweiten Weltkrieg gemacht
können Sie uns da noch mal erläutern wo
hier genau die Ähnlichkeit ist
ja die Ähnlichkeit besteht zunächst mal
darin dass man sagt wir brauchen
mechanisierte Systeme um Territorium
zurück zu erobern also auch die ganze
Diskussion in der Krise über die Creme
auch im Westen geht so von dieser
Vorstellung aus die ukrainische gegen
Offensive musste darauf zielen
Territorium zurück zu erobern und wenn
sie davon ausgehen dann heißt es
natürlich sie brauchen mechanisierte
Systeme also Fahrzeuge die tatsächlich
physisch durch das Gelände fahren und
hinterher kommt die Infanterie und
besetzt dann dieses Gelände und nimmt
das in ihn Beschlag und das ist eben so
das Denken des 20 Jahrhunderts und ich
erwarte etwas anderes weil sie müssen
nicht in dieser Art und Weise vorgehen
um operativen Erfolg zu erzielen es
reicht wenn Sie die russische Logistik
ausschalten bzw die russischen Verbände
so ein Kesseln oder so abschneiden
können dass sie einfach nicht mehr in
der Lage sind sich zu bewegen oder zu
offensiven überzugehen das heißt also
jetzt für diese Operationsführung die
Ukraine braucht nicht auf einer langen
Frontlinie durchzustoßen sondern es
würde reichen wenn sie an einen
bestimmten kleinen Abschnitt mit großer
Kraft zur Schwarzmeerküste durchstechen
könnte und dann die südliche Front der
Russen abschneiden sowie über Artillerie
die Krim abriegeln könnte das heißt also
die Idee ist nicht dass man mit den
Panzer dann durchfährt und quasi noch
auf die Krim rein und dann die Creme
zurückerobert sondern dass man den
Russen einfach glaubwürdig droht wir
haben auch Logistik abgeschnitten wir
sind an der Küste wir können von der
Küste aus jedes Ziel auf der Krim
beschließen und ihr seid jetzt defacto
abgekapselt also entweder zieht ihr euch
zurück oder ihr werdet halt aus der
Ferne dann herausgenommen und das ist
ein völlig andere Ansatz und der
natürlich nur ähm funktioniert wenn sie
eben wegkommen von diesem reinen
mechanisierten Gedanken und das ganze
Denken im Sinne des Gefechts der
verbundenen Waffen erstens und zweitens
auch im Sinne von
dass das der dass das physische halten
von Territorium weniger wichtig ist als
Gegner die Logistik abzuschneiden und
die Beweglichkeit
auf die ukrainische Strategie gucken wir
gleich noch mal können Sie uns noch mal
erläutern was jetzt genau die Abwehr
Analogie zu dieser Maginot-Linie ist die
wir aus dem zweiten Weltkriegen
ja so Analogie ist es eigentlich nicht
dass es ist so ein bisschen ein schiefes
historisches Bild also die die
französischen Streitkräfte hatten ja zu
Beginn ist des Zweiten Weltkriegs sich
sehr stark auf die Maginot-Linie
verlassen also um eine deutsche Invasion
abzuwenden und haben gesagt naja gut
wenn jetzt das das aggressive Nazireich
hier vorbeikommt dann werden sie ja ganz
sicher an dieser Maschine Reitern der
Gedanke hat aber nicht funktioniert weil
eben die die deutschen anders
vorgegangen sind also sie sind mit
massiven panzerkeilen an einzelnen
Punkten vorgestoßen und haben an manchen
Punkten die Linie durchbrochen und dann
andere Punkte haben Sie sie einfach
umgangen sie haben sie auch überflogen
also sprich mit mit Truppen die nicht
mechanisiert vorgegangen sind sondern
dann im Hinterland gelandet und dann
wenn Sie wenn Sie das so ein bisschen
als als Bild nehmen wollen dann zeigt
ihm das eben das
selbst wenn Sie eine massive
Sperrstellung im Gelände errichten und
die Maginotlinie die war deutlich größer
und deutlich stärker befestigt das alles
was wir jetzt in der Ukraine sehen
selbst dann ist das kein keine Garantie
dafür dass Ihnen das wirklich eine
Abschreckung bietet ein anderes Bild
wäre zum Beispiel der Westwall also wenn
wir es jetzt mit vertauschen Vorzeichen
sehen auch die die Wehrmacht hatte sich
ja sehr darauf verlassen dass der
Westwall quasi dazu führen würde dass
die Alliierten auf keinen Fall von
Westen aus weiter vorrücken könnten da
sehen wir es gerade auf den Bildern da
sehen sie auch eben diese Drachenzähne
aber man muss sich eben das Fundament
dazu denken ne also die Waren bis zu
einem Meter tief im Boden verankert
fünffach gestaffelt fast so hoch wie ein
Erwachsene ähm Personen an manchen
Stellen und da hatte man auch gehofft
naja gut durch so eine massive
Stellung kann der Gegner nicht
durchkommen ja und und dann gab es
einfach die Brücke von Remagen z.B
dabei haben die einzige intakte
Rheinbrücke die es die es noch gab wo
die US-Armee dann drüber ist also es ist
sehr schwer eben so zu sagen wir bauen
jetzt eine eine große Mauer oder einen
großen Ball und dann kommt da keiner
mehr drüber man findet immer Wege solche
solche Stellungen zu umgehen und wenn
das jetzt schon bei diesen sehr großen
und sehr stark ausgebauten Fällen des
Zweiten Weltkriegs der Fall ist dann ist
das genauso vorstellbar jetzt mit diesen
relativ schnell zusammen improvisierten
Stellungen entlang der
ja das mal als kleinen historischen
Ausflug und Bezug Hacker wir sprechen
gleich noch weiter zu ukrainischen
Strategie ähm bei der könnten übrigens
gleich mehrere Orte von Bedeutung sein
und einer davon ist occiativ in der
Südukraine und dort war unser Reporter
daran
jetzt noch mal einen Blick darauf was er
dort in den letzten Tagen erlebt hat
Botschaft vor dem Krieg ein beliebter
Ferienort seit Kriegsbeginn geht es um
die militärische Bedeutung der
Kleinstadt am Schwarzen Meer vom Cliff
oben sieht man die Landzunge gegenüber
sie gehört zur Krim dort nur vier
Kilometer entfernt sind russische
Stellungen
es ist unser Land unsere Ukraine die
geografischen Gegebenheiten sind kein
Problem für uns wir wissen wie wir sie
nutzen können damit der Feind sich
unwohl fühlt in seinen Stellungen und
weit weg will wir haben das bei der
Eroberung des Westufers im Vers und
demonstriert und jetzt bereiten wir uns
vor auch die andere Seite einzunehmen
die angekündigte Großoffensive werde
kommen mehr gibt die ukrainische
Militärsprecherin homemjuk nicht Preis
den Feind Russland über das Wann und Wo
zu verwirren ist Teil der Strategie
im Ort leben nur noch wenige Menschen
und das in ständiger Reichweite der
russischen Artillerie die Nervosität
steigt
du weißt es nicht jeden Moment kann ein
Geschoss einschlagen meine Verwandten
sind krank mein Sohn ist an der Front
wir versuchen hier zu überleben
die militärische Bedeutung von
den generieren unter der russischen
Zarin Katharina der Großen bekannt
bezeichnendweise richtete sich der Blick
auch damals in Richtung
ja und darüber wollen wir jetzt sprechen
mit Sarah der diese Bilder aufgenommen
hat daran hi schön dass du bei uns bist
hallo und du warst für diese Aufnahmen
in ucha kiff in der Südukraine richtig
jawoll wer waren dort und habe ein Bild
gemacht und
das heißt natürlich nicht dass von dort
aus die
Großoffensive Richtung stattfinden wird
es ist einer der strategischen Orte
die Landzunge ist in der großen Nähe man
hätte dann Zugang auf die Krims direkt
das gehört aber auch zum verwirrspüler
zu dazu dass die Topographie und die
Möglichkeiten hier in Ukraine überall
diskutiert werden
ja du sprichst du schon an alle rechnen
mit einer früher als Offensive keiner
weiß aktuell so richtig wo wie wann sie
losgeht du warst dazu wahrscheinlich
auch nicht mehr oder wie reagieren die
Menschen auch dort vor Ort
es ist das Geheimnis und das ist und es
ist auch die Frage die hier alle
beschäftigt vom Bäcker der die Menschen
die Politik die Militärstrategen alle
diskutieren die Frage wann geht es los
wo geht es los und heute wurde der Druck
eigentlich sogar noch weiter erhöht denn
das Verteidigungsministerium hat heute
verkündigt dass die ersten Maßnahmen die
zu dieser
Frühjahrsoffensive gehören schon
eingeleitet werden und im Osten ähm das
Landes stattgefunden hätten welche
Maßnahmen das sind und wie vorgegangen
wird und was es weiter für die nächsten
Wochen und Tage bedeutet dass er wurde
natürlich nicht gesagt ich erinnere mich
noch gut
an als letztes Jahr
da war auch unter den Journalisten eine
große Nervosität und ähm ja und und und
Engagement wo könnte es losgehen denn
die Sommer Offensive Zurückeroberung der
Region und Stadt her sondern wurde auch
so langwierig also und so langfristig
angekündigt es gab Kollegen die sind von
der New York Times erinner ich mich
wochenlang in mikolajew haben die
ausgeharrt das war eine Stadt die damals
keine elektrizitäten kein Wasser hatte
und dachten dass es so wie vorhin
beschrieben mechanisiert losginge doch
diese ganze Offensive im Süden fand
eigentlich nur über gezielte Schläge
durch Artillerie statt durch die
Unterbrechung der Logistik bis die
Russen im November dann die ähm auf die
andere Seite des Flusses nibro
zurückgegangen sind weil sie einfach
ihre 25.000 Soldaten im Herbst und nicht
mehr versorgen konnten ich hatte im vor
einer Woche mit einem Kommandeur in Kiew
gesprochen und ähm der war im Norden
stationiert und bekam plötzlich die
Befehle einzelne Stellungen anzugreifen
die Operationen waren äußerst
erfolgreich und dann kam der nächste
Befehl der nächste Befehl und er konnte
mir dann und dann war ich auf einmal ein
ishium sah andere Kommandeure mit ihren
Einheiten und wir gucken uns an und sagt
Mensch wir waren ja Teil von einer
Offensive das haben wir war ihnen gar
nicht so bewusst und wurde ihnen
vielleicht auch so bewusst gar nicht
mitgeteilt vielleicht war es aber auch
einfach ein Testballon der aufging und
man ist immer weiter vorgerückt es ist
alles sehr in der Schwebe und diese
Verwirrung dient dazu da dass der Feind
Russland nicht weiß wo der wirkliche
Schlag stattfinden kann und man agiert
er sehr flexibel sehr spontan und auch
glaube ich wirklich auch im Moment
okay das heißt nicht mal innerhalb der
ukrainischen Armee weiß man ganz genau
wer agiert und wie viele aktuell agieren
es ist ja auch für dich jetzt vor
ziemlich schwer aktuell von vor Ort zu
berichten oder da gibt's ja so bestimmte
Verbotszone
ja es ist nie leicht aus einem
Kriegsland zu berichten das sowohl das
Leid was die Menschen erfahren mit dem
man selber konfrontiert wird sowie die
Gefahr es ist jetzt ganz klar eingeteilt
worden in rote Zonen dort darf man nicht
berichten aus denen darf man nicht
berichten es gibt gelbe Zonen dort darf
man in Begleitung eines Presseoffizier
berichten wie das in der Praxis dann
ausgedehnt wird wird sich dann zeigen
und
die Motivation und die Begründung für
diese Einteilung so hat mir ähm die
Militärsprecherin der Südfront Frau
humanjok gesagt ist natürlich der Schutz
der ähm für die Journalisten die Furcht
das ähm
Artilleriegeschütze nicht berechnet
werden können das vermiete Gelände zu
opfern führen der das ist auch
berechtigt und das ist auch richtig
gefährlich andererseits kann man auch
davon ausgehen dass natürlich auch
Truppenbewegungen oder Stellungen nicht
durch zufälliger Reportagen enttarnt
werden sollen können und eventuell
Informationen an Russland liefern können
es ist ein Spannungsfeld zwischen
Militär die geheim halten wollen und wir
Journalisten die im Interesse
hoffentlich unsere Zuschauer berichten
wollen und das ist auch kein neues
Spannungsfeld vor allem nicht in
Kriegsgebieten
ja wir hoffen dass du da weiter für uns
dran bleibt und uns dann auch in den
nächsten Wochen alles berichtet was ich
in dieser Sache entwickelt vielen Dank
da
danke sehr
ja wir haben jetzt ganz viel darüber
gesprochen diese berühmt berichtigte
ukrainische Frühjahrsoffensive von der
niemand so richtig weiß wann sie losgeht
ob sie losgeht wir wollen aber zu der
jetzt noch mal mit unserem Militär
Experten Herrn Kolb sprechen der mir
jetzt wieder zugeschaltet ist hallo
hallo
wir haben ja jetzt eben schon gehört die
Russen rechnen eigentlich mit einem
mechanisierten Angriff sie sagen das
wird das ist eigentlich eine altmodische
denke und das wird in ihrer Voraussage
so nicht passieren können Sie uns noch
mal ganz dezent erklären wie sie glauben
dass so eine ukrainische früher als
Offensive aussehen könnte strategisch
ja also ich glaube ehrlich gesagt wir
werden erst merken dass diese Offensive
stattgefunden hat wenn sie fast vorbei
ist also das worauf jeder wartet nämlich
der der große Durchstoß mit den
westlichen panzersystemen also mit Leo 2
mit Scheibenwischer zwei mit mit dem
Bradley am 2 das ist wenn überhaupt der
Abschluss der Offensive aber sicherlich
nicht der Beginn ihr Korrespondent hat
das korrekt gesagt es gibt im Moment
einige verdächtig auffällige Operationen
auch und gerade an an äh frontsektoren
über die wir jetzt überhaupt nicht
sprechen also im ganz im Osten an der
donausfront wo wo selbst Ziele in der
oblastung ganz beschossen werden mit
Heimat ist es möglich dass das
Ablenkungen sind es ist aber auch
möglich dass das tatsächlich zu der
Offensive dazu gehört
auch sehr richtig gesagt die vergangenen
ukrainischen offensiven waren keine
eigentlichen mechanisierten Initiativen
sondern gezielten vor allem darauf die
russische Logistik abzuschneiden und mit
Artillerie den Russen klar zu machen
dass sie eingekesselt werden und
abgeschnitten von ihrer Versorgung wenn
sie sich nicht zurückziehen das war
eigentlich genau das Vorgehen in der
Operation zwischen fakiv und die Summen
die wir im September 22 gesehen haben
das war das Vorgehen bei der
Rückeroberung von Treffern und das hat
fantastisch funktioniert einfach weil
die russischen Truppen einfach nicht
lernfähig sind in der Hinsicht also man
kann jetzt pragmatisch sagen sie machen
die gleichen Fehler immer wieder sie
haben einfach auch gewisse logistische
Beschränkungen einfach Sie müssen sich
zwingend auf Eisenbahnlinien verlassen
wenn Sie die nicht zur Verfügung haben
müssen sie lange umständliche substitute
organisieren mit mit LKWs und
improvisierten munitionslagern die kann
man sehr leicht sehen und angreifen also
sprich die Ukraine hat in logistischer
Hinsicht einfach den Vorteil dass sie
die Russen da sehr empfindlich treffen
kann und ich sag das immer wieder man
muss über die ukrainische Offensive eben
nicht denken als mechanisierte Operation
sondern das Ziel ist dass die russische
Position unhaltbar wird und haltbar im
logistischen Sinne also sprich das die
Truppen nicht mehr versorgt werden
können aber dass die Ukrainer sie aus
der Ferne angreifen und abschließen
können das gilt für die Südfront über
die wir jetzt sprechen genauso wie dann
auch später für die Krimi also sprich es
ist nicht notwendig mechanisiert auf die
Creme vorzurücken wie das z.B mahnstein
gemacht hat 1941 im Zweiten Weltkrieg
sondern es reicht eben glaubwürdig damit
zu tun dass die gesamte Logistik auf der
Creme abgeriegelt wird und die russische
Position damit unhaltbar wird es sei
denn sie ziehen sich zurück
lassen sie uns vielleicht noch mal einen
Blick auf die Karte werfen die uns das
mal zeigt wir haben sie vorhin schon
gesehen wo eben diese Schutzwälle und
Gräben sind sie sagen gerade es ist
überhaupt nicht notwendig da überall
durchzukommen um wieder über vielleicht
auch die Krim zu sprechen können Sie uns
das hier einmal zeigen was sie genau
damit meint
vielleicht wenn Sie noch etwas stärker
auf den Nordteil der Krim hineinzoomen
dann dann sehen wir genau
da sehen wir jetzt so links oben sehen
wir die den Ismus von perikopf also die
Landenge über die die meisten
mechanisierten Invasionen der Krim
stattgefunden haben und ähm rechts da
sehen wir so eine ganz dünne kleine
Linie das ist die Landenge von arabert
auch da gab es im 19 und 20 Jahrhundert
Operation aber sie sehen es ist sehr
schwierig die Krim mechanisiert
einzunehmen also als Mannstein damals
1941 gemacht hat da das war eine sehr
blutige sehr verlustreiche Operation die
ging auch über den Ismus von perekopp
und sie sehen genau dort finden Sie auch
die große Konzentration an diesen Gräben
und Verteidigungsanlagen also sie sehen
klar die Erwartungshaltung wenn es eine
Invasion der Krim gibt dann wird die
wieder so ablaufen wie im Zweiten
Weltkrieg und
man muss das eben anders denken man muss
denken dass das Ziel der Ukraine wird
eher sein an die Schwarzmeerküste
vorzustoßen also irgendwo an die Küste
zwischen der Allianz und ähm und dem
Beginn hier dieser dieser arabert
Landgänge oder sie sehen was für ein
riesiger Raum das ist ja aber sobald sie
da sind und Raketen Artillerie dort
aufstellen können also sagen wir mit
einer Reichweite zwischen 80 und 170 km
dieses System hat die Ukraine dann
können Sie im Prinzip jedes Ziel auf der
Krim treffen das heißt dass sie können
sozusagen aus der Ferne verriegeln und
damit die Position der Russen unhaltbar
machen weil sie einfach jedes Ziel dann
erreichen können und damit glaubwürdig
drohen können nicht nur die russische
Logistik abzuschneiden die befindet sich
nämlich ironischerweise ganz im Norden
der Krim in jangoi das ist der zentrale
Eisenbahnknotenpunkt und wo auch die
Munitionslager sind auch eine wichtige
Airbase und wenn sie sehen das hier
diese diese große Konzentration hier von
Gräben gerade nördlich von John Koi
und wenn Sie wenn Sie diese Logistik
hier rausnehmen dann können Sie sich
ganz leicht vorstellen da kommt nichts
mehr auf die krimin hinein und nichts
mehr aus der krimin hinaus dann haben
sie nämlich nur noch ein Zugangsweg
nämlich die Brücke von Kirch und ich
vermute mal das wird auch der
Rückzugsweg sein den man den Russen
offen halten wird also das ist ein
Szenario wie der Krieg enden könnte man
ähm also wenn man dieses operative Ziel
erreicht dann sagt man den Russen schaut
ähm ihr seid jetzt eingekapsel auf der
Creme entweder zieht ihr euch zurück wir
lassen die Brücke von betroffen oder ihr
werdet einfach vernichtet ist ein
mögliches Szenario ist sicher eines der
optimistischeren aber ich denke dass das
unmittelbare Ziel dass wir dass wir uns
klarmachen müssen ist die Russen müssen
prognostizieren wo genau die Ukraine
durchbrechen und landen wird nochmal die
gesamte Frontlinie ist 1200 km lang und
die Abschnitte über die wir hier
sprechen da sprechen wir über
küstenlängen von 100 bis 300 km und die
Russen müssen jetzt den Punkt ausmachen
an der Frontlinie wo geschieht der
Durchbruch und wo ist der Endpunkt und
sie können sich vorstellen weil bei
diesen riesigen räumen wir müssen uns
immer klar machen die Ukraine ist größer
als Frankreich und diese orange
markierten Gebiete diesen ungefähr so
groß wie die Schweiz und Österreich
zusammen
es gibt in der Idee von der Größe der
Räume über die wir hier reden und die
Russen müssen jetzt einen Punkt
prognostizieren waren also einen einen
kleinen Durchmesser von vielleicht drei
bis fünf Kilometern wo dann der
mechanisierte Durchstoß erfolgen wird
wie machen sie sowas oder also die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie falsch
liegen ist natürlich sehr viel höher als
die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie richtig
liegen auch die Möglichkeit dann spontan
noch irgendwie um zu disponieren wenn du
Durchbruch woanders stattfindet als sie
gedacht haben die sind natürlich auch
beschränkt das heißt also das ist genau
was ihr Korrespondent gerade gesagt hat
die Ukraine ähm fördert natürlich auch
diese Diskussion und Spekulationen ganz
bewusst auch in ihrer eigenen Propaganda
einfach um zu sagen ja es kann im
Prinzip überall sein ist gehört dieser
Beschuss jetzt da im Osten wirklich zu
der Initiative oder ist das ein
Ablenkung kommt sie jetzt kommt sie erst
im Mai es ist wirklich eine Kakophonie
von von ganz unterschiedlichen auch
widersprüchlichen Äußerungen und ich
denke nicht dass das Zufall ist
ja sie haben uns gerade an der Karte ja
recht anschauliches skizziert was so
eine Theorie von ihnen wäre ich habe
jetzt auch gelesen es gibt eine andere
Theorie dass die Offensive auch über den
Norden erfolgen könnte hätten sie das
für realistisch über den Norden wo von
jemand durch die Landenge von oder
das halte ich ehrlich gesagt für wenig
realistisch also peripop ist eben so
diese diese klassische Landenge wo die
mechanisierten Operationen stattgefunden
haben also sowohl mahnsteins Invasionen
auf die Creme als auch die sowjetische
Gegenoffensive die die Deutschen wieder
rausgedrängt hat auf aus der Krim die
erfolgte auch über den Raum das glaube
ich ehrlich gesagt nicht weil ähm dafür
bräuchten sie sehr viel mehr Material
als die Ukraine im Moment zur Verfügung
stellen könnte es wäre auch eine sehr
sehr blutige Angelegenheit also wenn wir
die ganze Kriegsgeschichte anschauen so
in in diesem Raum also wir können auch
bis ins 19 Jahrhundert zurückgehen dass
das wäre sehr Ressourcen intensiv und es
würde auch sehr lange dauern also ich
glaube dass ehrlich gesagt nicht
ich muss mich einmal korrigieren mit
Norden war vor allem die Region um hakiv
gemeint das sind wir hier noch mal auf
der Karte genau das quasi als Theorie
die ist auch aktuell gibt wie schätzen
Sie die denn ein
ja man hat das mal geglaubt also in als
die als die verkaufsisierung Operation
gerade zu Ende war im September da hat
man dann geglaubt ja ja jetzt könnte die
Ukraine wenn Sie die Kräfte mobilisieren
kann weiter vorstoßen also in Richtung
ebenfalls ein zentraler Logistik Knoten
vielleicht wenn wir die wenn wir die
Karte noch mal sehen könnten oder wenn
die User selber mal auf die Karte
schauen und die die Stadt ist
herausfinden wollen das ist jetzt etwas
zu zu zu konzentriert wir müssen etwas
reinzoomen ähm aber es dauert es ist
eben dieser zentrale logistiknoten und
der ist nicht allzu weit entfernt von
derzeitigen Frauen Verlauf das heißt
dafür müsste die Ukraine erstmal durch
das war doofe durch also durch die Linie
die ist im Moment stark befestigt und
auch umkämpft und dann müsste sie
vorstoßen aus der Dienst also undenkbar
ist es nicht wir haben im Moment nicht
so viel Informationen wie es aussieht
mit der truppenkonzentration in diesem
Raum
aber die Ukraine hält sich im Moment
hartnäckig auch etwas südlicher im Raum
die man also es ist möglich dass
vielleicht so eine Zangenbewegung in von
beiden Richtungen erfolgt das würde aber
voraussetzen dass die Ukraine im Raum
statore Kräfte mobilisiert hat also ich
halte es nicht für undenkbar ich bin
jetzt aber nicht genügend informiert
über die Logistik in dem Raum um jetzt
zu sagen halte ich für wahrscheinlich
oder unwahrscheinlich
ja wir werden es wahrscheinlich
irgendwann in den nächsten Tagen in den
nächsten Wochen erfahren lassen wir uns
noch mal auf die User Kommentare und
Fragen gucken die Community interessiert
sich vor allem einer technischen
Perspektive Perspektive für diese
russischen Aufbauten Welle Gräben und
hier fragt big Edge auf Youtube könnten
diese Schutzwälle ein Leo zwei A6
aufhalten und das ist eine Frage die
ziemlich oft gestellt wird hier fragt
noch jemand auf Youtube können diese
Hindernisse mit modernen Waffen nicht
einfach weggebombt werden kann das
wirklich Wirkung gegen moderne Systeme
zeigen
ja also sie sie würden durch solche
Hindernisse nicht direkt mit einem
Panzer durchfahren sondern der der die
Panzer Durchfahrt wäre eigentlich das
letzte was sie machen würden also sie
würden zunächst mal alles was im Graben
ist bzw um den Graben herum ist direkt
attackieren idealerweise würden sie es
eigentlich mit luftmitteln tun
ersatzweise mit Artillerie dann müssten
sie zunächst mal die Minenfelder
herausnehmen die hinter den Gräben
liegen also mit mit sogenannten line
charges würde man das machen also mit
mit einer Spezialmunition die kann man
abschließen die Fliegen das Minfeld und
lässt die Minen dort deponieren also
sprich man muss nicht nur den Graben
herausnehmen sondern auch dass dahinter
liegende Territorium und das müsste man
alles entsprechend vorbereiten und
sobald das dann vorbereitet ist kann man
dann in der letzten Phase mit den
mechanisierten Geräten durchstoßen aber
das ist nicht unbedingt neu jetzt in der
Kriegsgeschichte also sie können gerne
mal selber googeln also es gibt sehr
sehr gute Beschreibungen wie man solche
Stellungen angreift und überwindet das
ist eigentlich so klassisches
mechanisiertes Handwerk also das ist
weder besonders schwierig noch noch ist
das unbekannt das ist einfach eine Frage
von Ressourcen es ist vor allem auch
eine Frage von Logistik weil sie müssen
einfach denken es kommt nicht nur darauf
an dass sie durchstoßen sondern wenn
dieser Vorstoß passiert dann passiert
der schnell ähm das heißt sie bewegen
sich also sehr schnell sie überwinden
große Distanzen und die Logistik die
muss sofort hinter ihnen quasi hinterher
rücken damit sie weiter versorgt werden
mit Treibstoffen Munition sonst bleiben
sie nämlich mitten im Gelände stecken
während sie noch vorstoßen und das wäre
das das Dümmste was Ihnen passieren kann
ja apropos Gelände es gibt hier noch
eine weitere technische Frage aus der
Community Jürgen Wörter sagt auf Youtube
die Offensive wird noch dauern im Moment
ist der Boden noch zu weich um schneller
Angriffe zu ihnen ziehen die sollten
aufhören mit dem Kaffeesatz lesen
solange die Bedingungen dafür bereit
sind gibt es da tatsächlich gerade eine
Mitte logische Komponente die diese
früher als Offensive behindern könnte
sie spielen wahrscheinlich auf die
rasputica an also diese diese Periode
wenn die die Ukraine so schlammig wird
und und die die Wege dann versinken also
da muss man zunächst mal differenzieren
also dir das Putty zur ist im Osten
anders als im Süden der Süden hat ein
Steppen und Wüstenklima das heißt der
ist sehr viel trockener und sehr viel
sonniger als der Don Bass das heißt ähm
da haben wir mittlerweile keine rasputer
mehr in Don was noch also es gibt schon
eine meteorologische Komponente die gilt
aber vor allem eigentlich dann wenn sie
sagen okay wir wir fahren eben nicht auf
den Straßen sondern wir brechen massiv
durch das Gelände durch es ist aber
durchaus denkbar und dass die Ukraine
z.B sagt naja gut wenn jetzt diese
Gräben da sind die Gräben befinden sich
ein Wesentlichen im Gelände wir könnten
aber auch versuchen uns erstmal einen
Korridor ähm um die Autobahnen herum zu
ähm zu sichern das heißt also dass man
sagt wir sind uns gewisse Zugangs Routen
ohne jetzt uns mit den Gräben überhaupt
zu befassen das heißt wir müssen so ein
Korridor von vielleicht einen Kilometer
rechts und links der der Autobahn
einfach sichern so dass sie dann schnell
auf befestigten Straßen durchstoßen
können ich weiß dieses Argument mit der
das kommt immer wieder ähm es ist nicht
irrelevant aber ich würde sagen gerade
im südlichen Frontabschnitt ist es ist
es im Moment weniger relevant als
vielleicht dann irgendwas
und die Zuschauer und Zuschauerinnen
interessieren sich auch für die
geliebten Pentagon Dokumente auf
Facebook schreibt Marion Ben es läuft
eher schlecht für die Ukraine
Kernaussage der Pentagon Dokumente Kiel
werde seine Ziele vermutlich Zitat weit
verfehlen und hier fragt auch jemand auf
Youtube Batman was hält Herr Korb von
den Einschätzungen der Amerikaner
bezüglich der Geliebten Dokumente
ja man muss zunächst zwei Dinge wissen
also der der Stand dieser gelegten
Dokumente ist ungefähr Februar diesen
Jahres und es handelt sich eigentlich da
so um um typische
Geheimdienst Einschätzungen deren
Erfolgsquote sage ich mal variabel ist
dass es finden da so ziemlich alles von
trifft einigermaßen zu bis hin zu ist
kompletter Unsinn es ist eigentlich
interessant dass in diesem Krieg die
Geheimdienste also auf allen Seiten bei
den Russen genauso wie beim
amerikanischen meistens falsch gelegen
haben wenn man mal ab sie davon im
Januar ist also ist klar dass das
Russland die Invasion starten wird und
das im Gegenteil die die Open Source
intelligence eigentlich meistens richtig
liegt also die Leute die sich
Satellitenbilder besorgen die
Eisenbahnstrecken studieren mit Leuten
vor Ort reden und so weiter es ist es
ist ein ironisches Element dieses
Krieges dass die Geheimdienste die ja
sehr viel Geld dafür bekommen eigentlich
bessere Informationen zu haben bisher
eigentlich keine haben also wenn ich
jetzt mal überlege was ist alles
prognostiziert worden von von gewissen
generellen die gesagt haben militärisch
ist die Sache gelaufen bis hin zu den
Statements den es geht ja ohne Ukraine
dies aus oder Ukraine kann ich gewinnen
oder Tralala ich bin mittlerweile sehr
sehr sehr gelassen geworden gegenüber
diesen intelligence berichten ich gucke
mir einfach an was passiert konkret
Objektiv auf dem Schlachtfeld soweit ihr
es jedenfalls beobachten können und da
würde ich sagen gibt's im Moment
eigentlich wenig Grund zu Pessimismus
ich würde sagen diejenigen die im Moment
ein Problem haben sie die Russen weil
ihr Material im Raum bachmut massiv
abgenutzt wird weil sie jede Fähigkeit
zu Offensive verlieren weil auch das das
trainiertierte Personal dass sie mal
hatten weit den drauf gegangen ist in
den Kampfhandlungen jetzt durchs ersetzt
wird und ich würde ihn doch raten er von
der Perspektive die Dinge zu sehen also
zu beobachten was tatsächlich passiert
statt sich auf Informationen als dritte
Hand zu verlassen
jetzt dient ja als Grundlage für diese
Pentagon Papiere aber auch die mangelnde
militärische Ausrüstung der Ukraine und
nach der Fragen hier auch einige im Chat
wie ist es denn aktuell wirklich um die
bestellt ja also ich weiß nicht wo
dieses Argument immer herkommt also die
Ukraine hat weitaus mehr Menschen unter
Waffen als die russische Invasionsarmee
jeweils Menschen hatte also sie müssen
bitte denken die Ukraine hat allein im
Februar 8 neue Brigaden aufgestellt je
nachdem wie sie zählen hat sie zwischen
einer halben und zwei Millionen Menschen
unter Waffen also 2 Millionen wenn Sie
die gesamten Territorialverteidigung und
alle hilfsgruppen mitzählen die
russische Invasionsarmee hatte auf dem
Höhepunkt der Invasion Ende fehlt nur
190.000 Angehörige und ähm ich weiß wer
es geistert immer diese Zahl herum
300.000 Menschen hat Russland angeblich
mobilisiert ich frage mich wo sind sie
alle weil bisher haben wir nur ein
Bruchteil davon eigentlich in der
Ukraine gesehen ich weiß ehrlich gesagt
nicht woher dieser Pessimismus kommt
also sie können gerne mal auf die auf
die Seite
militaryland.net gehen da sehen sie die
brigadenaufstellung der Ukraine da
können sie mal die Kampfbrigaden
zusammenzählen eine Brigade hat zwischen
5 und 8000 Mann es gibt die eine
ungefähre Idee was da für ein Potenzial
herum steht und gerade mit westlichen
Waffensystemen ausgerüstet wird also ich
würde sagen wenn es Grund zur
Pessimismus gibt dann würde ich den
Pessimismus eher bei den Russen
ansiedeln als bei der Ukraine ich weiß
Deutschland ist seit 20 Jahren durch
seucht von russischer Propaganda und
viele finden es schwer das zu glauben
aber ich kann mich nur wiederholen ähm
betrachten Sie die Zahlen und schauen
Sie sich an was Objektiv tatsächlich
passiert statt irgendwelche emotionalen
Stimmungsbilder zu zeigen
und wir haben abschließend noch eine
Frage zur gesamten ukrainischen
Strategie aktuell in diesem Krieg und
zwar mit auf Youtube gefragt wieso geht
die Ukraine so wenig gegen die
Nachschubwege vor hätte das nicht mehr
Nutzen als also ein abnutzungskrieg wie
ein bachmut zu führen wenn ich Sie
richtig verstanden habe dann tut die
Ukraine aber genau das oder also sie
versucht logistisch Schwerpunkte
abzuschneiden sie tut es schon ich denke
was was der User meint ist sie könnte
sie könnte durchaus mehr tun wenn Sie
die entsprechenden Systeme hätte also
sprich wenn sie wenn sie stärker mit
Raketen Artillerie ausgerüstet wäre wir
haben ja sehr stark in der Vergangenheit
diskutiert sollte sie nicht auch attack
MS also diese Langstrecken Artillerie
mit 150 km Reichweite bekommen da sage
ich immer die Ukraine hat das System
Grimm 2 das ist eine ukrainische
Eigenentwicklung mit bis zu 170 km
Reichweite das Problem ist einfach man
hat die Ukraine bisher einfach sehr
zögerlich unterstützt nach dem Motto wie
es ein gewisser Bundeskanzler ja mal
gesagt hat die Ukraine darf nicht
verlieren und das ist natürlich Unsinn
sie beenden den Krieg am schnellsten
dadurch dass sie die Ukraine in der Lage
versetzen die Russen herauszuwerfen und
das heißt insbesondere in die Logistik
abzuschneiden also die Ukraine macht
schon das richtige aber die
Möglichkeiten das massiv und in der
Fläche zu tun die sind einfach begrenzt
ja wie auch immer ist zu diesem Thema
weitergeht ich bin mir sicher wir werden
dazu noch mal sprechen vielen Dank Herr
Kolb bisschen
ja schönen Abend noch
ja ich bin mir sicher dass auch ihr und
ich da noch einige Male darüber sprechen
werden ich werfe zum Schluss noch mal
einen Blick in die Kommentare und sehe
hier einen Kommentar auf Youtube der
sagt toller Experte deutlich
verständlich erklärt gut ja wenn ihr
weiterhin up to date bleiben wollt was
den russischen Angriffskrieg in der
Ukraine angeht dann kann ich euch
empfehlen auch bald wieder ZDF heute
live einzuschalten ich freue mich immer
über eure Kommentare und die
Diskussionen vielen Dank